the chiefs had their
brush with a coveted 19 outbreak
potentially we saw that two guys were
abruptly placed on the covet 19 reserve
list earlier this week senator then
senator daniel kilgore and receiver
demarcus robinson
apparently it happened because
they were getting their haircut by a
barber
who tested positive and the news of the
positive test
came as roughly
20 other chiefs players and employees
were ready to get a haircut from this
barber
including patrick mahomes
so so uh the good news is neither kill
kilgore nor
robinson have tested positive the bad
news is kilgore
didn't get his haircut finished he
tweeted a new profile
that's great it is there it is
that's yeah i love it that is not that
is not real
pete is asking us to remind everyone
that he is not walking around like that
although i fully endorse that look if he
chooses to do it
he did get the haircut finished so
daniel kilgore and demarcus robinson
were the guys who ended up in the covet
19 protocol
simply because of that close contact
with the individual who had tested
positive and that's what the nfl has
done this year the
the intense protocol the procedures for
high-risk individuals who have been in
contact with those who are positive
and for the most part those individuals
don't become positive cases but the nfl
wants to make sure because
you don't want those guys around their
teammates in the event that they begin
shedding virus so
that has worked out apparently for the
chiefs but here's the thing
i don't want to jinx anybody i i don't
want to reside in our fears
but the reality is thursday friday
saturday
sunday four days left positive test
for any player any coach any key member
of
any team staff you're done it's it
you're gone
ten days well do the math 10
10 days puts you beyond super bowl
sunday and as we saw all season long
chris
i don't think even if patrick mahomes
would test positive and yeah i said it
oh you can say i jinxed him
if you believe in things like that but
even if he does they're still playing
the super bowl on sunday yeah i would
think so
i mean it would certainly take away from
the luster of the football game but it's
a great reminder of just like how fickle
this whole thing is
i mean it just it's one little misstep
still
i think where it's shocking is we went
what like basically two and a half weeks
without hearing anything about covid
right i mean it was really since what
wild card the week before the wild card
game
where we had a brown the browns right
and then we went this period of time
where it was nothing and you kind of
just thought
hey it's it's we're out of the woods
it's we're done we're down to the final
few teams it won't happen nothing like
that
this comes about yeah scary scary it's
got to be scary for the nfl the chiefs i
mean dodging a bullet
certainly and i you know who knows
maybe that'll be a lesson for the tampa
bay buccaneers this is a very common
practice in the nfl
where a day off you know a tuesday
or friday because those days could be
shorter right for
a work day as far as players can get out
of the building maybe around
2 o'clock 2 30. so those are days where
guys will go all see a barber or
and i don't think this is happening
right now but before the pandemic
the barber would be in the locker room
when you'd get done with practice and
he'd cut everybody's hair that way
so very commonplace and scary
glad nothing happened and hopefully the
bucks don't go
get you know go see the barber as a team
on friday afternoon
yeah well but here's the reality now
and i i wonder how the nfl would handle
this
because if you had that exposure on
friday yeah right
you're not going to be positive until
after the super bowl
the incubation period carries you past
sunday that would be
an awkward situation for the nfl at that
point
and clearly what the nfl wants to do
right now is
check that final box 268 games
out of 268 possible games have been
played
one is left and the super bowl will be
played the nfl
is not going to put the brakes on it or
delay it
because for example and just to be equal
here
patrick holmes or tom brady test
positive or any other players test
positive unless there is evidence of an
ongoing
outbreak and i guess a cynic would say
well they'll say there is
if they want to get the best players on
the field but that's what it's going to
take
to delay the super bowl i mean really i
think we're close enough
i think we're close enough that we can
say there's a pretty good chance this
game's getting played on sunday i would
think so
i i really would um i mean yes it just
it seems like everything's going in the
right direction
i would think that that would be one
more you know warning shot across the
bow to get everybody to like
whoa that's scary let me you know make
sure i do everything right this week and
hopefully everything goes on a schedule
but i mean it would be crazy
it would be crazy if a superstar went
out for the super bowl i mean i i don't
even want to put my brain there or
anything like that
it would almost be unfulfilling yeah as
a viewer
i mean if one of those names went down
one of those big time players weren't in
there because of covid whoever the
quarterbacks
chris jones whatever shaq barrett does
dion joe
you know uh devon white it it would
almost be
underwhelming feeling i think if you won
that way too
that's just something that jumps out to
me like if it was brady
that wasn't out there and the chiefs won
i think they'd be like man
you know we won it's great but it's not
the same we'd like to beat them at their
best or the opposite if it's you know
the bucks winning and
mahomes was out but uh i i don't want to
have to talk about that that's enough of
that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports